in this lecture we start our discussion  of continuous random variables we will  focus on the case of a single continuous  random variable and will describe its  distribution using a so called  probability density function an object  that will replace the PMF s from the  discrete case we will then proceed to  define the expectation and the variance  of a continuous random variable and will  see that their basic properties remain  unchanged there will be one new concept  the cumulative distribution function  which will allow us to describe in a  unified manner both discrete and  continuous random variables even  so-called mixed random variables that  have both a discrete and the continuous  component in the course of this lecture  we will also introduce some of the most  common continuous random variables  uniform exponential and normal we will  pay special attention to the normal  distribution and the ways that we can  calculate the Associated probabilities